let's talk about where we go from here
with joe biden as crack pottery
msnbc's eugene robinson describes
biden's speech as urgent wartime address
as network keeps evoking civil war shut
up fox news network keeps evoking civil
war civil war is trending constantly
over the past couple several months
msnbc's tiffany cross has claimed it
feels like the civil war is here in fact
she said more than that they have a
video clip here let me see if i believe
this is the one maybe it will play maybe
it won't have the state all right let's
uh every time well because we were
listening to music we have listen
parties before every show
there is no let's deal with the rhetoric
at this point i do think we have to have
serious conversations around preparing
for actual violence uh people keep
saying a civil war is coming i would say
a civil war is here and i don't mean to
be hyperbolic we can look at what has
happened just in the past week alone
since all this has happened we've had
two people try to declare war with fbi
field offices i don't think at this
point we're going to all pack up our
bags and go home and sing kumbaya
she's right yup she's 100 right it
doesn't matter what side you're on or
who you think is factually correct or
morally correct what matters is that
there were people going to fbi field
offices one guy tried to break through
and i said yeah people are getting
violent you know these things are
happening and even it was uh
eric weinstein what is this auto play
video boo
eric weinstein said uh he doesn't see a
path uh out of this and and i'm like you
know with like that that's that's that's
great i've i've been saying that for a
while and i don't mean that as like a
dig at him i'm like even he's now saying
you know even joe rogan is saying i
think tim was right a civil war is
coming even erica saying i don't see a
path out of this i said that a year ago
i mean violent crime has been on the
rise for the last two years i think i
have to look at the numbers again but i
think it coincided before the pandemic
was exacerbated by the pandemic we
obviously saw the summer of 2020 which
was marked by violent riots
you know it's hard to say whether the
civil war is coming or we've been slowly
drifting into it for some time i think
people expect there to be like a referee
whistle and for it to be like and we've
begun and that's never in history ever
been the case even even fort sumter
they didn't know if that was the start
of a civil war or not they were shooting
at each other like well you know this
could be nothing we don't know
and uh people can't see the force for
the trees yeah i'm looking at this quote
from joe biden last night we can't allow
violence to be normalized in this
country but violence has been
increasingly normalized in this country
for so long i mean by him yeah and how
many times do we have to see like random
person stabs elderly women on the
streets of new york before we see that
violence is happening on so many levels
of our society in a way that we're not
used to can we get a joe biden clip
where he's standing in front of the red
you know shaking his fists and then we
just have like one of these lefties
going are we the baddies yes you are
it's you cheering on law enforcement and
governmental expansion and and violence
against regular people you know i want
to give a shout out to uh these left
commentators the social commentators who
are cheering on joe biden right now who
cheer on antifa because when antifa went
and smashed the windows of the working
class throughout a bunch of cities in
this country they cheered for that that
makes you the bad guys like you know if
you want to talk about evoking history
or invoking history then um
crystal knocked sure
you were the guys who went around
smashing up everyone's windows and guess
what you did it in black neighborhoods
there's viral videos of people in black
neighborhoods begging antifa to stop
destroying their homes but whatever you
didn't care did you so you know what
when these people tweet like ben shapiro
tweeted you know biden's gone crazy and
i see hassan and vosh and they're like
seethe and laughing about it it's like
yes you guys they're they're evil they
they don't care that antifa went
destroyed the lives of working-class
people they're in favor of the elites
and the system i mean hassan bought
himself a multi-million dollar house
while claiming to be a socialist bravo
good sir that's the griff that's the
racket
you've done it very well
so when uh when the lockdown started i
want to give some context to this when
the lockdown started the first thing
that my wife and i did was go to home
depot and buy plywood to board up the
front windows on our capitol hill home
because i had no idea what was going to
happen but but my theory was that if you
lock people up
and you tell them that they can't go to
work and you tell them
dictating every aspect of their life
things are going to get violent and
that's that's precisely what happened
maybe maybe it was orchestrated but i
but i think another theory about what
biden is trying to accomplish and i
think this msnbc clip proves that
is that they want someone to take the
bait
they want to be able to point to some
mega guy that goes too far and gets
violent so that their narrative
completes right yes see i told you they
were going to get violent
um so one way to think about one one way
to another way to think about that
speech is let's goad them into doing
something stupid
yes and then that's our narrative for
the election yes i like that theory
because it seems like social chaos is
brewing as a result of the lockdowns
since september 11 2001 people have been
out of their mind
pointing the finger at who's in who's at
fault but like uh
it seems like an emergent phenomenon
that it is a violence of desperation and
that yeah
to acknowledge that would be like well
we've been riding off the back of the
federal reserve for 120 years this is
what happens when you defer your your
monetary responsibility and let people
print your economy into oblivion yeah
well just think about all these things
what they've done to children and and
all of the developmental damage by not
being able to go to school or masking
all of the people that died because they
weren't allowed to go to the hospital
and maybe they died of cardiovascular
disease maybe they died of cancer maybe
they couldn't say goodbye to their
parents who were dying
the list goes on and on these these
inhuman indignities that that have been
imposed and fair or not and i think it's
fair the the biden administration the
democrats msnbc the lockdowners owned
this problem so they have to come up
with something else because they're not
going to win
on the health of the economy they're not
going to win on even though they say so
they're not going to win because they
open the schools because that's a lie
so what are they going to do they're
desperate and they're trying to stoke
civil war
it's disgusting
i i think
civil war has been here for a while and
i think what we're seeing of them has
been an increasing desperation because
they've been losing
over the past several years there's been
a i mean since trump won no before that
i think it was even since obama was
president because it's a global civil
catastrophe we're in like a global civil
uprising where a new government's
attempting to form a one new world order
they're calling it and obama signing the
trans-pacific partnership like getting
on board with selling out to the
malaysian oil companies was part of it
it's like creating this corporatocracy
but trump was very against that and so
is bernie sanders which is kind of why i
think why he got snowballed by the
clinton campaign they were not really
into like yo let's sell out the people
to the corporations and acquiesce to the
metaverse you know uh
mute mutation um and but that was like
slowing it down and i don't know if
biden's like in on it or if he just is
being pushed along with it bidenism he's
i mean he's he's part of the the regime
he's a part of the machine
um someone's writing his talking points
for him i i want to white peel you guys
just for a second here
um think about think about the
trajectory you mentioned the tea party
but you could go back to ron paul you
could probably even go back to howard
dean
um and you could certainly fast forward
and look at bernie and trump as
outsiders breaking
the two-party duopoly
and and doing something that that the
establishment didn't want
and
every
step along the way
they've tried to whack it down it's like
whack-a-mole oh people are finally
speaking for themselves it turns out
that not every democrat wants hillary
clinton it turns out that not every
republican wants mitt romney
and there's this uprising going on
fueled by technology this is the upside
of technology it is democratization at
its best
and it turns out that people have a
voice and they have power and they have
control
and and this is this uh existential
fight that we have between the machine
that wants to crush us
and people that want to be free
and i i think we're in the middle of
something it maybe it's a civil war
maybe we're figuring out how different
other americans are across the country
in a way that we couldn't have possibly
known before
technology but maybe we're also trying
to figure out how to beat the man
and reorganize things in a more
decentralized way i think
one of the things we're seeing
you know i mentioned those people that
would just say or do anything to fit in
or be cool
they've
they've become stuck where they are and
so
they're all it's a mexican standoff
they're all looking at each other saying
what should i say and what should i do
and there's no real leader anymore it
used to be that with a centralized media
apparatus you could say
blue is the new green and then all the
people go
yes blue blue
now that leader is gone
now it's all of just them and one guy
goes green green no wait
blue i don't know canceled they're
attacking each other and so they're
stuck and there's no way to lead them
out of it an example is
you know i i've been watching she-hulk
have you guys watched that great piece
of american um media first episode i
i like the first episode the second
episode was okay the third episode was
just one of the worst pieces of
film trash i've ever watched because
she's a good actor too it's really bad
it's it's just like the it's they're
making they're ruining characters but
anyway i digress it's it's getting bad
reviews it's got like a 2.2 or something
like that in in out of five
and so what these cultists do is they
say the only reason that's happening is
because white supremacists are attacking
it and then i'm just like it's really
funny because i actually liked the first
one i thought it was silly when she did
that rant about feminism but i was like
i even said in the show i was like it's
all right you know c plus it's like kind
of funny second episode it's okay you
know there's some bad stuff in it and
third episode is just really really
awful and it's like what do you say to
someone who actually praised the first
two episodes the first two weeks and is
now saying okay it's getting bad is that
racism and white supremacy the issue is
when there's no leader they don't know
what to say so they say bad thing they
say
the only reason people don't like it is
because they like bad thing
they they like bad things so they don't
like show and and you're just like maybe
if you had
charismatic thought leaders they could
explain what's wrong with the show in a
way that would help your side but they
don't it's a mob
and you know some people call them the
real fascists or whatever and i'm like
it's just a mob it's a group of people
marching around with pitchforks
figuratively on twitter looking for the
next person to be angry at over their
problems joe biden is a part of that mob
he is not a leader he doesn't know what
he's doing somebody writes them a speech
because they're a part of the mob and
they're saying mindless nonsensical
garbage but mobs are dangerous yeah it i
mean they're also just there's an
apparatchik mind mindset
to to people like this because the you
know the prize the ring
is is control of the federal government
and without that they can't impose their
will on other people
um whereas i think um conservatives and
certainly libertarians don't really
think that way we're not
we're not ultimately political animals
we want to live our lives we want to
raise our families
we want to
live our lives the way we see fit
and and i think that's sometimes a
disadvantage when so much power is
concentrated in washington dc
um apparatchiks win
and people that that want freedom don't
even understand what they're doing um so
that you know the language is foreign
like what are you guys even saying it's
it's hard to even understand what
they're trying to say i think they're
trying to get you to agree with them by
using the only thing they know which is
fear so they're saying like
well only white supremacists criticize
she-hulk so therefore if you are going
to criticize it know that you are
equating yourself to that ideology and
so in turn if you don't want to be
outside the group you start to be like
well i kind of like the costumes in
she-hulk and even though you didn't
actually like it you feel like you can't
publicly talk about it otherwise you
were equated to dude
it's it's like the show's bad because
the writing is bad the jokes don't make
sense the characters are being ruined
like wong he's in a bunch of movies he's
a great character and they made it they
turned him into a joke like he's
disheveled he shows up late he's
committing crimes i'm like what is what
is this what are they doing these
characters but the cgi
so bad you know it's yes like
but bad is an understatement it's worse
than shrek people are like ah shrek
level cg i'm like no man the way they're
like walking and jerky and their mouths
are moving like this when they talk i'm
like it reminds me of sims you know yeah
game like it looks like early early
animation of sims like in the worst way
possible and this is like a
multi-million dollar production right
every you know what i think i think when
you're a when you're a part of a mob
they're they they they may be able to a
mob can break into cnn but they can't
make the cameras operate the cameras may
already be turned on when the mob breaks
into the cnn you know headquarters so
they can move the camera around and
point it and that that that goes out to
the world but eventually the camera
stops working and they start scratching
their heads then someone comes in and
they're like uh let's do this and they
press power the camera starts working
but not working well and they're like
okay i got it that's what it feels like
like a mob broke into to to the uh you
know the studio and they don't know how
to work anything
and that's and you know i think merit is
being shut out but uh we're doing our
own things that's the danger of
corporatocracy is that merit gets shut
out and wealth dictates who gets to make
the decisions instead of the the most
intelligent or the most resourceful
which is what republicanism is so great
for that the merits of of the human are
what lead the way not that not the bank
account
well i mean is is it is it wealth or is
it is it woke-ism where where
who you hire is not based on the people
that could actually make a good movie
right i think i think that's what you're
describing oh man remember when like
star wars was completely destroyed and
then it was completely destroyed and
then it was completely destroyed and
like every step of the way they just
completely ruined the ip
like the prequels it's like okay you
know whatever they they they really ham
fisted it it's like why is c3p0 and
r2r2d2 here that's anakin built see
that's weird but fine whatever we all
had a good laugh we enjoyed it then i
started making a whole bunch of weird
garbage and then the sequel movies were
just
nonsensical garbage
ryan johnson who's super woke just
totally ruined it and he brags about how
proud he is but he legitimately ruined
it the rate like it's dude george lucas
sold out he sold star wars to disney he
sold out that was his ip
the freakish well good for him
he ruined it he gave up and he ruined it
first of all forcing his own direction
on it ruined it george you ruined the
first episode one you ruined because you
didn't let someone else take the reins
for you you're a good story writer
you're not a good director my man that
movie was terrible
jar jar binks was a laughingstock oh you
mean you had a horrible child actor to
play the lead you had no villain you had
darth maul who didn't even have lines in
there like one line in the movie
terrible terrible i thought you were
talking about a new hope i was like what
the new hope was good episode four five
and six were freaking incredible man
yeah they're an amazing cast confusing
how they did these these yeah i've never
understood it i've never really followed
want to make i feel like you're making a
really hot take i just wish i could
understand that he wanted me to pretend
like i didn't know palpatine was the
emperor so that i could like
the kids in the future will watch star
wars from episode one forward nuts this
is crazy
do you like star wars i i checked out
with jar jar binks and
i've had to go back and re-watch them
all recently but but i'm i'm probably
surely the oldest person here and i was
a
very young maybe i was like 12 when the
first one came out and that that was
like iconic definitive this was part of
our youth back then yeah
and um you know the first three which i
don't know which numbers they are
are four five and six four five and six
they just call them one two and three
whatever yeah prequels and the sequels
and then jar jar binks i'm like i'm out
yeah yeah how racist was that all this
like cgi cartoons i would rather had a
dude in a costume like that's what they
did in the original star wars dudes with
costumes on playing music and that's
shot first
oh and then they re-edited the star wars
to make han not seem so villainous like
han's a dirty dude of course he shot
first he shocked us so they didn't get
shot this is an example actually you
know i remember when they changed star
wars so that greedo fired at han first
and it was a big deal and i'm like this
is like it's like proto-wokism when they
started chain when they started making
content to fit their ideological
narrative going back and editing it
because they were like han shouldn't be
a scoundrel he should be a hero well and
they're hijacking they're hijacking
stuff that is necessary you said this
you were 12 when this came out it's a
huge part of your childhood they're
hijacking things that they know people
will want to watch to put their own
messages in didn't wasn't there like a
netflix show they went back and edited
the first episode was it stranger things
i think there's a bunch of them done
that's crazy because you know i remember
when uh when video games used to be
released the video game that came out
was the video game you got and when they
were bugs well you know too bad and
sometimes they go it's not a bug it's a
feature like the idea of in video games
a combo in a fighting game right in
street fighter it was actually a bug
that you could string together a bunch
of moves creating a no time gap between
when you attack and your opponent's
ability to defend and they were like
it's a feature they couldn't do anything
about it nowadays when when a game is
released they patch it
now they're patching tv shows
this is nightmare like time is gone
like
history memory won't matter because
you're going to go to your friend and be
like hey did you just watch that new
show called you know about ian you know
ian and matt's adventure into you know
the never ending detail or whatever and
you're going to be like oh yeah it was
really awesome when ian pulled out the
lightsaber
lightsaber what are you talking about no
he had a ska excalibur
what no he draws a lightsaber dude i
just watched it bro i watched it when it
came out that's what they're doing
they're working on augmented reality
where depending on who you are you're
going to see a different image on the
screen so like for kids when they watch
it they'll see coca-cola but when an
adult watches it they'll see beer a bud
light i'm just watching a video on this
it's crazy or when adults watching it
they'll see you know a big apple being
like make sure you eat healthy kids and
then the kids are gonna be watching it
and it's gonna be a giant tiger throwing
gummy snacks and i'm being like eat
candy it's it's delicious or something
the parents are gonna think the kids are
getting a good message not realizing it
that's disturbing because part of what
bound us together you might have
mentioned this earlier is is our shared
me i don't know if you said this exactly
but our shared appreciation for a shared
understanding of what art was like i
don't know if you actually said the
surveys you tim but like we would all
sit around it was fox news gave us the
this is what's up tonight and everyone
would see it everyone could agree that's
what i saw for better or worse because
we were led astray in many ways and but
now we're gonna even be like that's what
i saw well that's what i saw did we even
see the same show i don't know and i
don't know how to verify it yeah how
crazy is going to be
if you know
we we no longer have tvs we just have
like viewing portals that are green
screens and you put on your ar goggles
and then you're watching the news and
you get different news at the same time
like i mean we saw this with the sandlin
testimony the gordon silent testimony um
there was a gym i think it's a gym
someone posted this photo
cbs and fox next to each other and on
fox it says sandlin confirms no quid pro
quo and cbs says sandlin confirms yes
quid pro quo it's like you literally
have two different
truths that are coming out and it's like
another good example has just happened
taiwan shot down a chinese drone it's
reported by you know a bunch of outlets
that it was a chinese drone why because
it came from china but then you get cnn
saying unidentified drone and reuters
saying suspected chinese drone and now
what happens is someone might go did you
hear that they shut down a chinese drone
they'll go no it wasn't identified what
are you talking about the news said it
was literally this is insane i don't
know how we function this way well
i'm gonna wait till you guys again
because i i really feel like um back in
the day like i'm the old guy again i'm
gonna be old guy all night but um i'm
old enough to remember when walter
cronkite would tell me as a kid that's
the way it is and you got 20 minutes of
spoon fed news and somebody curated that
and all three networks said the same
thing
and that was our only access to
information
and now you have these infinite sources
and all sorts of contradictions these
these contradictions of fact
prove to us
that that a lot of what we used to think
of as objective news is at best opinion
and perhaps just
blatant false propaganda
but we have we have the ability now to
to sort of fact check the fact checkers
and i think that that put maybe puts
more responsibility on us to figure
things out for ourselves and yes all
sorts of people are going to fall for
the bs but
um i i feel more comfortable in this
crazy decentralized world than i ever
did when someone was dictating to me
what to think
it's all broken man i feel less what
we're seeing but more hope what we're
seeing now with uh with the media and
the lies plays perfectly into the
post-modernist
goals sure the fact that you have fox
and cbs saying the exact opposite things
it is it is perfect for them that we who
will try and fact check and then present
to you the best to the best of our
abilities the facts it they like that we
come out and say they're lying to you
and at the same time they point back and
say they're lying to you because it
confuses people
but good for numbers and yet
that's sort of how life works right you
think about you think about your
everyday life and you're trying to
figure out how to move forward in a
radically uncertain world it's a world
we live in we live in real time and we
don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow we have some sort of theory
about what happened yesterday and
somehow we figured that stuff out so i
think i think it's important not just to
take the snapshot of like that guy says
this and this guy says the opposite and
i don't know what to think um there's a
process by which we're gonna figure this
stuff out
and
but again like we have to like own that
instead of just falling into the trap of
believing
one tribe and not the other thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you